I work as a hospice nurse my job is
working with people that are at end
stages of life and because of that it
has changed my perception on the value
of our time and the value of my life and
just wanting to just savor every moment
of it and I think when we are mindlessly
scrolling and not realizing what we're
actually spending our time on we are
missing out on precious moments that we
will never get back I assure you that my
patients are not wishing that they had
spent more time scrolling they're
wishing that they had spent more time
with their family they're wishing that
they had taken the risk that they were
afraid to take so ask yourself what your
priorities are and if you feel like
you're suffocated in the busy and the
rat race and just running between one
thing and another and that you don't
have time for all the things that you
have to do maybe just cutting back some
time on your social media or your
endless scrolling might go a long way to
just reduce all of that noise and give
you more peace and calm during your day